we're very pleased that we've been able
to
uh give all elderly care home residents
virtually all
elderly care home residents have now
been uh given
their first job or a slot for their
first jab
and that's that's very important if you
for
getting the spread of the virus i'm
getting the
the serious illness and the fatality
done
we must make sure that we go forward
with the second jab for everybody as
well
a few have already had the second job as
you know but everybody will get one
within 12 weeks of their first job and
we're confident that we have the
supplies to do that and
people are coming forward at exactly the
right rate at the moment
does it appear as though these latest
lockdown measures are working
are you confident that hospital
emissions are starting to fall now
we're starting to see some signs of
flattening
and maybe even a falling off of
infection rates and
hospitalizations but don't forget that
they're still
at a very high level by comparison
with most points in the last 12 months a
really very high level
and so the risk is if you take your
foot off the the you know
the throat of the the beast as it were
if you allow things to
to get out out of control again uh then
you could at last see the disease
spreading again
fast before we've got enough vaccines
into people's arms that's the
that's the risk and some of the new
vaccines that
uh show results late last week were
shown to be slightly less effective
against the south african variant are
you concerned that
that that variant could undo all the
hard work that we've seen for this
latest lockdown
we're confident that all the vaccines
that we're using
provide a high degree of immunity and
protection against all variants and
the interesting and exciting thing about
uk vaccinology
at the moment the vaccines that we're
developing is increasingly
they are capable of being adapted to to
deal with new variants as they arise
the fact is we're going to be living
with kovid for a while
to come in one way one way or another i
don't think it will be
as bad as the last 12 months of anything
like
of course but uh it's very very
important that our vaccines continue to
to develop and and to adapt and they
will and we're hearing that astrazeneca
will be providing some extra
vaccines to the eu um are you nervous
that there might be another
row with the eu when it comes to vaccine
supplies we're very confident of our
supplies
and the supply chains that we have and
are very very pleased with the the
vaccines that we've got
but i want to stress that providing
vaccines inventing vaccines
is an international effort these are
done by scientists working together
across borders and the uk is the
one of the leading if not the leading
country in advocating cross-border
corporations so
we're the second biggest funder for the
whole kovacs initiative
which is designed to spread vaccines
around the world we helped to raise 8.8
billion only a few months ago for
vaccines across the world
one of the great things about the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
is that it is distributed at cost so
it's capable of benefiting literally
hundreds of millions
if not billions of people around the
world and captain tom moore in hospital
with coronavirus
what's your reaction to that well i
spoke to the
family last night and all i can say is
captain tom moore has been
an inspiration to everybody in this
country
during this pandemic and i think our
thoughts and our prayers are
now with him and and with his family
we've got some regional questions now
um we've seen the pandemic
disproportionately impact people
here in yorkshire last week we visited a
food bank in hull
and last year they were having around 60
to 100 visits per week they've now got 6
000 visits per week similar economic
impact in bradford as well
what can you do to ensure that these
towns and cities don't get even further
left behind because of this pandemic
there's no question that the pandemic
has disproportionately hit
some areas in some communities and
places that have been effectively in
lockdown
for many many months and so it's
inspiring to come here to the archima
center in
in badly and see the work that
volunteers
are doing to distribute uh food
parcels to to help people throughout the
community
and we in government are going to
continue our work to
to support that whether through
supporting local uh government as we as
we do
uh about 4.6 billion gone into local
government already
uh but also supporting good local
charities in what they're doing
it is going to take a while for our
country uh to bounce back
completely uh from from kovid and all
sorts of things that need
uh to change into and to get better
the economy i think can bounce back very
very strongly the uk has immense natural
resilience but the thing that really
concerns me at the moment is
education and the deficit in our
children's education
that we've run up as a result of these
lock downs and
that is for me going to be one of the
major major priorities
for us in the next few weeks and months
making sure that we
remediate that we repair the
the loss of time in the classroom the
loss of educational
opportunities for for millions of kids
that's a massive
it's a chance for us by the way to do
some things better
and we're going to focus on that as well
we're looking particularly at
uh one-to-one uh tutoring uh the good
that that can do
and all sorts of other things but uh
you're absolutely right
it's areas uh across the country that
have been hardest hit that have been
longest in
uh in lockdowns that we're going to have
to focus on particularly